25 years ago today Serb forces captured
the bosnian town of Schreiber Nitsa and
carried out Europe's worst massacre
since the Second World War a ceremony is
underway to remember the thousands of
Muslims killed in the atrocity the
anniversary is being marked in the
shadow of the global coronavirus
pandemic which has not only meant that
commemorations have been scaled back but
has also again delayed appeals hearings
in the trial of the main culprit Serb
general rata lot H was eventually
convicted of war crimes and genocide but
the families of the deceased are far
from closure three bones and a shred of
cloth and yet the revelation of a sad
fate one of 8,000 victims of this
reverent itzá genocide is recovered here
from a mass grave in eastern Bosnia the
bones are later brought together
Catharine bomb burger is the director
general of the International Commission
on missing persons she has been
instrumental in finding and identifying
the bodies of the disappeared she cannot
put this ribbon itzá Genocide behind her
yeah in many ways every day this issue
now 20 years later Bonn burger moved to
the Hague from the Bosnian capital
Sarajevo a few years ago in this
state-of-the-art lab where DNA is
extracted from skeletal samples and
analyzed came with her the genetic codes
can then be compared with the DNA of
survivors but this is not only about
victims finding closure not only that
the bodies were found and allowing
families to bury them in an art case
using DNA to accurately identify them
but also ensuring justice for the
victims and that's been a road that has
we've embarked upon but is not over yet
the lab results have been used in
various trials in 2017 the International
Criminal Tribunal for the former
Yugoslavia
found the main perpetrator of this
ribbon Itza Massacre the former Serbian
military
Ratko Mladic guilty of committing war
crimes and genocide he was sentenced to
life in prison on July 11th 1995 not
each and his troops over and and
occupied seven itza where tens of
thousands of Bosnian Muslims had sought
safety this is rarely shown footage from
the Criminal Tribunal for the former
Yugoslavia a Dutch battalion of un blue
helmets was supposed to defend the UN
safe haven but many soldiers looked on
as Nottage had the men and boys rounded
up they were taken away and murdered in
mass shootings over 8,000
but there was more horror to come I mean
the perpetrators went back to the
original mass grave sites and to cover
up the evidence they used heavy
machinery they went back to the original
sites and dug up bodies from primary
locations and moved them to multiple
secondary locations often fifty
kilometers away from each other the u.s.
detected the genocide by analyzing
satellite images victims had been buried
across Serbian controlled eastern Bosnia
some skeletons were torn apart then
years later under the eyes of the
Bosnian Serb authorities the dead were
exhumed so this went back to the
forensic pathologist who would then look
at cause and manner of death which was
often difficult because heads would be
missing I mean it wasn't always possible
to to see bullet wounds because often
they were executed in the head of the
head is missing I mean I'm getting into
the gory details but this required
probably the most meticulous scientific
effort ever conducted in a post-conflict
situation and specifically related to a
genocide the aim is to allow family
members to properly bury their deceased
loved ones anthropologists are piecing
together their human remains it's
possible that this came from one
individual and this came from a
different individual
a daunting task today experts can rely
on DNA analysis that make their work
easier samples are extracted from the
human remains sometimes from a whole
range of them this has allowed the
experts to more or less piece together
skeletons of the deceased by comparing
these DNA samples with those of
relatives the ones nameless victims
regained their identity working with
traumatized families of the missing to
try to receive DNA samples from them and
to match the samples to the post-mortem
skeletal remains that were being found
in mass graves what began in cerebra
Nitze is now a widespread method for
identifying victims it's used the world
over to identify those killed in wars
and other conflicts and Surin itza is a
reminder of what we're all capable of
regardless of which country were from
that level of hatred results it can have
a very very bad ending and I am scared
Catherine bromberger says it's up to us
alone whether or not we learn from the
past I'm now joined by professor hirez
Halil Yvette's a social anthropologist
and award-winning writer at RMIT
University of Melbourne Australia a
little [ __ ] has written about the
long-term effects of the Bosnian war but
more importantly sir you are from
Shravan itza and have relatives who were
killed in the massacre there what does
this day mean for you like to everyone
who survives reddit said this is they
most of us are conscious about for the
whole of the year it's not just a one
time a year event for most of us this is
something we think about our daily basis
some are affected more than others and I
know that my aunties and my uncles and
my cousins for example are much more
directly affected than myself I happen
not to be certain it's at a time of
genocide and
eight seven I was you know my early
teenage years however as catching
Bombeck I described finding a Bourne
getting identified piecing all these
pieces together has been a very ongoing
process for many very traumatic
experience to go through so it is a
humbled a day of remembrance and day of
reflection for all of us as it should be
for everyone else understood the war was
fueled by nationalism some will say that
nationalism is on the rise again in many
parts of the world do you see any
similarities to what is happening now
and and what happened back then before
the war broke out well what is probably
most disappointing is to see exactly
that continuation of the old wartime
nationalist rhetoric and not obligatory
but also the policies and kind of the
whole culture being confused by this
type of nationalism that start was
started before the war in terms of
dehumanizing other ethnic groups in
terms of justifying crimes that way to
be committed or even those that pay
community in genocide studies we have
different stages of genocide from
dehumanization to perpetuation of actual
physical killings to denial what we have
seen in impossible Bosnia the region is
going beyond the denial it's actually a
culture of triumphalism where genocide
is even justified mocked victims
humiliated and all this is not only
allowed but also promoted from above by
the hardcore nationalist elites those in
Serbia and in part of both the Republic
of Srpska
they are especially active in that and
this has also penetrated onto ordinary
people's lives with songs and jokes
about genocide becoming almost unknown
rather than a form of extremism
yes it's very worrying threatened Harris
a little Evita I just want to ask you
interest in ten seconds
how do we make sure this doesn't ever
happen again
well the purpose of genocide studies is
really prevention learning from the past
in order to prevent and recognize any
potential risk for future genocides we
need to acknowledge what happened but
also we need to combat every other form
of exclusion and unfortunately and sadly
we have seen those not only the
rhetorical level but also in terrorist
attacks in Norway and here in New
Zealand Paris a little of each I really
appreciate your time thank you so much
professor for global urban in social
studies at RMIT University in Melbourne